tonight a man accused of driving drunk
and killing a mother of three near
durango and russell on thanksgiving back
in 2019
is sentenced after taking a plea deal
nathan postel will spend
eight years in prison with a max of 20
years
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
sat down with the mother and brother of
the victim
who say they finally feel some sense of
closure
yes monique's family watched as they
watched the man
accused of killing the mother of three
finally sentenced this was on monday
i spoke with the family about how
they're doing a year and a half later
after the crash
and what this all means to them so we
went into this small room
and we waited and this woman came in and
she was wearing a uniform
and on her uniform she had the letters
coroner's office in gold
and before she could say anything i
looked at her and i said my daughter's
dead
isn't she monique prado a daughter
sister and mother
of three her life taken in an instant as
she and her eldest daughter went out for
a coffee run thanksgiving morning
in 2019. her family speaking out after
monday's sentencing
said after postel reached a plea deal
for killing prado
while driving under the influence of
alcohol and cocaine
i thought the judge was fair
i she listened to everything we had to
say on both sides
and and i feel the sentence that he got
which was the maximum of 20 years
was deserved these were his actions
nobody else caused this
prado's family didn't have high
expectations giving prior sentences
they've seen with similar cases
so when they heard the verdict they
immediately felt a sense of closure we
can begin the grieving process
we can begin to heal and we can begin to
move forward with our lives because
we've been stuck for the past year and a
half postdale will be eligible for
parole
after eight years but could spend up to
20 years in prison
this has impacted our lives and the
lives of her children
we are responsible for our choices that
we make
he made some really bad choices that
resulted in
the death of someone
and mr postel did have a prior felony
that was in 2014 before this crash
even happened that was for possession of
a controlled
substance reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now